good morning everyone we're very excited
to have you all here and look forward
very exciting day on behalf of president
Salome and provost Ben [ __ ] I welcome
and bring their greetings to you there
they apologize that they can't be here
today but we're very glad to support and
sponsor today's day of data this is our
sixth annual day of data with a focus
this year on data on earth as our we
enter into our sixth year we reflect
back on why we actually created this
program and if we go back six years the
the reason why we created this program
was what we were finding and those of us
in the library and the Yale Center for
research computing was across the campus
across many many different disciplines
we were encountering researchers and
students and faculty who were working
with data and often had very similar
problems though they were in different
disciplines and so what we were hoping
to do was to help to foster a community
of practice to foster an opportunity to
share across the different disciplines
so that hopefully in the techniques and
methodologies of working with data we
would be able to create a network so
that individuals could realize that in
different departments and in different
disciplines similar problems were being
tackled often with different types of
data but with similar methodologies and
so this has been a creation over the
past several years to really foster that
community and as we look across the
auditorium today and see so many people
here from so many different disciplines
we feel very proud that this is
continued and it seems to be serving
that original purpose so today we're
going to start off with a wonderful
keynote and it's my pleasure to
introduce to you today Professor William
missioner I'm going to provide a very
condensed version of his 48 page CV for
you
professor missioner is a professor and
director of the East science initiatives
at the University of New Mexico's
college of university libraries and
learning Sciences in addition he directs
New Mexico's National Science Foundation
and the department of energy's EPS core
program and is the program
I'm sorry isn't is the primary
investigator for dataone the data
observation network for earth a large
cyber infrastructure project supported
by NSF he has published extensively and
by that I mean close to 200 publications
in the field of ecology information
science and marine science he also
serves on several nonprofit boards and
is the editor of ecological archives and
associate editor for ecological
informatics his talk today is entitled
managing data throughout the research
lifecycle to enable new science and
support decision-making drawing from
examples from three international
research efforts a professor Michener's
talk will focus on tools principles and
approaches that can be employed to
empower research within and across
different domains
[Music]